[Music]
foreign
this is my first Twitch streaming with
many I hope you will enjoy it
today I'm gonna talk about how spring
boot integrate well with the kubernetes
so we're gonna look at how
basically out of the box is spring boot
application can be naturally deployed on
a kubernetes environment will go step by
step it will be a Hands-On session so I
will do live coding all the time
starting from a spring boot application
we'll see how to tokerize it so how to
package it as a container
we're gonna deploy it on Docker and
finally on a kubernetes cluster so we're
gonna look at different things like
configuration service Discovery liveness
and Readiness probes and also some tips
about how to establish your local
development workflow when you work with
kubernetes
about me I'm the author of the book
Cloud native spring in action that is
available in Early Access on the Manning
website having said that
let's get started right away
I'm gonna code in IntelliJ so
the starting point for any
spring project is start.spring.io of
course
and here I'm gonna select the Gradle
project the latest production ready
version of springboot
I'm gonna
set some parameters here we're gonna
build a demo service application I'm
gonna use jav11 and S dependency I'll
pick reactive web
then actuator
lombok and
the configuration processor
so the reactive web dependency contains
all the libraries to build a reactive
web application in particular we're
interested in exposing the rest API and
by default we get a Neti server
spring boot actuator it's very very
useful in production because it exposes
a lot of different information so it
gives us
a lot of visibility into what is
happening inside the application lombok
is just to it's a convenient library to
reduce some boilerplate code like to
establish gather Setters and
Constructors
and finally the spring configuration
processor that we're gonna use on the
IDE just as a convenient way of
generating metadata
that's it I'm gonna generate the project
yes and I'm gonna open it up in IntelliJ
so the actual content of a spring boot
application doesn't change the
capability of being deployed on
kubernetes so we're gonna do something
simple
let's give it a second to build the
project
so locally I'm using SDK men it's a very
convenient tool that I recommend to
manage uh different Java versions you
can install it on Mac Linux and also
Windows you can select different open
jdk versions from different vendors and
you can have different versions of the
jdk it's very convenient if you're
working on
maybe testing compatibility with job 11
or 15.
it's a very seamless experience
that's what I'm using let's double check
yeah exactly so I want to use Java 11.
and this is just a standard spring boot
application we get
the auto-generated files in the startup
project we have
the entry point to the the application
we have a property file
I will change it to yaml because
I usually prefer working with yaml so
I'm gonna rename it to application yamu
yes
and then a test just to verify that the
context is loaded correctly
all right
so the first thing that we're gonna do
is defining a custom property it will
help us demonstrating different
configuration scenarios
both in Docker and in kubernetes
so what I'm gonna do is creating a
configuration bin I'll call it demo
properties
and in Spring boot we can use The
annotation configuration properties this
will Define this bin as a configuration
and in order for the framework to
actually be aware of this beam I have to
annotate the application
to scan the configuration properties and
there's an annotation for that
I have to define a prefix so all the
configuration properties starting with
pre with this prefix will be
serialized into this bin
it will contain only one property let's
call it message
and here I'm gonna use lombok to
generate
gathers headers and Constructors
now a nice thing about the last
dependency that I added to the project
the configuration processor is that it
can generate metadata for custom
properties automatically so if I add a
comment here saying for example a
welcome message to the user
and then I build the project
from Gradle
what happens is that the ID will
help me
using these custom properties just like
any other properties
and there's something happening here
sorry about that
yes
all right
so now I can use my
property so with this prefix
the final property will be called demo
Dot message
so I can go and say Timo
and this is Young of course
message
this will be maybe welcome to
springwoods
all right
yes next let's define a rest endpoint
that we can use to do a test on
kubernetes
I can use here a traditional rest
controller but
I can also go with the different
approach that is now available both for
spring MVC and spring web flux that is
relying on some functional endpoints
instead of rest controllers
so what I'm going to do now is defining
a beam here
that will return a router function of
server response
and here I can say the return
route and
then I can define a get endpoint
it gets on the root so just slash and
then in here
I can use a Lambda to return something
and since we are using spring reactive
this is gonna be a reactive object so it
can be either mono or flux in this case
it's just a single value because we want
to return the message so I'm gonna use
the the model
and this is a server response dot ok
now in the body we want to use the
property that we have defined in the bin
so I'm gonna do this I'm gonna inject
the property spin
and
Define a mono
with just this value
dot get message
and this contains a type of string
what's the issue here
foreign
come on okay router functions
Dot routes
okay
and then get
and we have
request
yes
and build
all right
so this is it simple application will
return a message that we defined through
a custom property
so
we can directly run it by default we
will run on Port 88 so let's see
I'm gonna go with the boot run
so the boot front task is building the
application as a jar artifact
that's one of the nice things about
spring boots that jar artifact can run
everywhere as long as you have a jvm and
that's the starting point to build a
Docker image
this is the application running
and
let's see if it's working 8080
here it is welcome to Spring boots
here I'm using a little tool that is
called HTTP if you're interested
it's very convenient I prefer it
compared to curve because
yeah it's much more intuitive
so I recommend you give it a try if you
use very often the command line
yes so one last thing before we move on
to containerize the application that I
want to show is that whenever we build
the application we get a jar file
that for Gradle is under build lips
so instead of using the boot front task
I could directly run the jar file from
here pointing to that path build leaves
and then the jar
and that's it so
from this point on so we have a very
simple spring boot application it could
actually be complex it doesn't matter
what you have inside
because the next step it doesn't involve
changing anything in your code
containerizing a spring boot application
since version 2.3 is actually uh very
very simple you don't need to create a
Docker file you don't need to import an
external plugin but directly in your
Springwood plugin for a Gradle or Maven
so the one that you're already using to
build your application you can also
build a Docker image
no Docker find no extra files and uh in
in Gradle is called boot build image
that's a similar task in maven
same functionality
and by default this task will generate
an image that is called like the project
in this case demo service
but we can customize it usually it's
better
so incredible is going to be built to
cradle but maybe you're gonna do this in
the pump.xml file
at least two things that you would
probably want to do is defining the
image name
and since I wanna push this image to my
Docker Hub repository I'm gonna use my
username on Docker Hub that is also my
repository name and then instead of hard
coding the name of the application and
the version I'm gonna use the variables
substitution in gravel
so I'm gonna use the project.name that
is the demo service column and then demo
dot version
not demo sorry project.version that is
the version defined up here
the next thing I'd like to do is to be
explicit about which version of the jdk
I want to use in this case I'm using
Java 11.
so I can Define that by passing some
environment variables here
this means that I'm getting the last
Java 11 version
let's run it and then I explain the
syntax and what does this mean
first I'll stop the application that is
running a chart file
I'll start the task
and while that is running I'll explain
what is happening under the hood
so I'll go to buildbacks.io
this is the tool that is implemented
inside the springboot plugin for Gradle
and maven this is a specification this
project is part of the cloud native
Foundation
and spring is using an implementation
that is called paqueto
this buildback specification Works in a
way that it detects
what are you using in your project and
then it Maps what you're using with
existing recipes to build images so in
the case of spring boot it will detect
that is a Gradle project first and also
that is using Springwood so it will use
a builder image that contains these
structures to build
and a good darker image around spring
boot
the implementation is uh paquetto
if you're interested
you can find in the packet of build
packs documentation all the
configuration properties that you can
specify so like this environment
variable here is specified there BP
stands for build packs
yes
the task run correctly let's have a look
so the image that has been built is
named like this docker.io is the
registry name that is prefixed for all
images on Docker Hub and then the name
that is specified
you can see if you're interested all the
the steps and all the things that this
Builder is providing is not just the jar
file and the jvm but it's providing
several different utilities like
certificate configuration and one thing
that I like is the memory calculator so
it computes at runtime depending on the
deployment environment it computes how
much memory to configure for the jvm to
run
and now I can take this image and push
it
to my toggle registry
if I want to
now I'm doing this manually but actually
this task
has also a possibility to specify the
configuration for pushing the image for
you directly you can do that by using
this configuration
and then you specify a username
and
a password
and the URL for the registry
now this is called password
but I really recommend not to use a
password so
if you're using Docker hub
but also for other registry you can
generate a token a single purpose token
that you can control better than the
password you should never expose your
password to put your password anywhere
so this one
can is your username but instead of the
password just use a token if you're
using Docker Hub you can find
instructions in your profile settings
about how to generate the token
and then the URL that in the case of
dollar would be
tower.io
once you have this configuration
parentheses issues
so let's write something
so this is the username this is the
token once you have this you can still
run the same task but when you want to
also push the image
you can run
put build image and then you specify
also a parameter that is published image
yes so we have a Docker image before
moving on to kubernetes let's see first
if it works
I'll remove this because I'm not going
to use it
and I'll use a double compose file
to do that
this is called demon service
and the image name
in this shown here
yes you can Define container name
demo service and
let's publish ports
let's keep 8080 88 okay
let's see if it works
and it failed
all right let's see what's happening
there
okay
um
let's do like this
foreign
issues with IntelliJ probably yes here
we have it
so first of all I can check the logs
demo service
so you can see here how he's calculating
the jvm memory based on my uh
on the resource available so my computer
when it's starting so it will first
run some pre-configuration for the jvm
and then we'll start the application
at this point let's see if it's still
working for 8080 root endpoint
welcome to Spring boot
now since we are in a running in a
Docker container we could actually
overwrite that application that
application property
there's different ways to overwrite
configuration in Spring usually you have
in your application yaml or property
file some default values and maybe it
acts also as a specification of what is
possible to configure and then you
override it with different ways one way
is to use environment variables
and we can do that
directly in the docker compose file here
I can specify an environment variable to
overwrite the demo message property the
convention in Spring is that if you have
a property like this
so it's uh
it's demote.message right
environment variables are usually all
uppercases
so we'll transform this property name
into all uppercase letters and then we
convert the dots into underscores
so this property will become
table underscore message or uppercases
and with the underscore
and this can be equal to welcome to
springboots on docker
all right and finally
let's update the application
foreign
so now we can go
okay now I started
so we can go and now we should get the
new value that we specified with the
environment variable here it is welcome
to Springwood Tom docker
all right
that's perfect let's remove this without
compose down
so if we sum up what we have done so far
we wrote a simple spring boot
application there was nothing in there
about where the application is deployed
the only thing that we did to
containerize it and deploy to a Docker
environment was to use external
uh
commands so with boot build image we
built an image and then we the
traditional Docker compose of Docker CLI
we can start the container so the
application didn't change and then we
saw also a way to override properties
through environment variables with
docker if we want to customize the
configuration